hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zum kontakt hier am
montag weil ich es gestern einfach nicht
geschafft habe weil ich samstagabend
unterwegs war und dann hab ich sonntag
halt zu nacht gar kein schlaf bekommen
habe ihn nur drei stunden geschlafen
habe dementsprechend dann auch bei
instagram ein bild gepostet was jetzt
halt eingeblendet seht wo ich halt um 11
uhr dann schlafen gegangen bin von 11
uhr bis 16 habe ich dann gepennt und
dann habe ich gerade noch so hero
irgendwie dann hingekriegt das ganze
noch dann veröffentlichen zu machen dies
dass ananas oder bis 15 ich weiß gar
nicht genau
jedenfalls hab ich halt von meinem
schlaf her und von meiner müdigkeit her
nicht hingekriegt die kamera auszupacken
und dann den kontakt aufzunehmen
deswegen tut mir sehr leid ich hoffe ihr
seid auch zufrieden wenn das ganze jetzt
ja montag kommt und zwar wie ich gerade
schon als wie instagram quote erwähnt
habe der kontakt heute wird über
instagram gehen und zwar zehn typen von
leute die es auf instagram gibt die mich
teilweise aufregen oder dies halt
einfach so gibt also das muss wenn ich
mal alles aufregen sondern einfach so
leute die es halt gibt bei instagram und
ich habe das ja schon mal zu facebook
gemacht damals auch noch auf luca filmt
das video blende ich euch mal hier einer
könnte hier draufklicken da seht ihr
zehn leute oder einfach nur unnötige
leute auf facebook die mich aufregen und
außerdem geht luca film war kurzzeitig
mal live kanal durch sowie videos
gemacht habe das geht jetzt so halb
weiter da uns war mich jetzt einfach mal
da ein video hochgeladen was ich gut
morgen gelernt habe wo ich einfach mal
gefragt haben ja was haltet ihr davon
wenn ich einfach so da wie loks darauf
mache also einfach das hochladen was mir
quasi für den kontakt zu peinlich ist
also so was wie wenn ich spaghetti koch
oder wenn ich gerade im fitnessstudio
bin oder irgendwie sowas wenn ihr das
wollt dann könnte von mir aus auf den
kanal youtube.com 2 stuka film gehen und
da einfach mal vorbei gucken ja sonst
würde ich sagen fangen wir dann jetzt
mal mit dem video an mit denen instagram
typen platz eins sind für mich so die
mavs platz eins also als erstes wollte
ich die leute so vorstellen die einfach
alles licon das sind so leute also ich
bin jetzt jemand auf instagram der jetzt
schon ein bisschen mehr follower hat als
jetzt so irgendwie normal
normale person bei mir ist es halt so
dass ich halt nicht benachrichtigungen
bekomme wenn irgendein foto legt aber
wenn man kann diese benachrichtigungen
da gehen und dann gibt es einfach so oft
leute die einfach dann erstmal jedes
foto von einem licon da steht dann so
100 mal untereinander der gleiche name
und alle like und der der light dann
jedes einzelne bild und das wird immer
als neues bild angezeigt da steht doch
nicht so wie bei facebook so dem und dem
gefallen drei fotos von dir sondern da
steht dann irgendwie pro gamer iks
gefällt das gefällt dies dies die
sixties alles untereinander und das
nimmt einfach diese ganzen neuigkeiten
weg wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel auf
ebenen kommentar antworten möchte dass
das sehe ich zum beispiel gar nicht weil
das den ganzen platz wegnimmt also
erstens so die leute die einfach alles
licon direkt auf einmal zweitens sind
die die einfach zu voller vorfall machen
die schreiben dann unter jedes bild von
einem irgendwie hashtag f 4f so voller
vorfreude hashtag follower steckt voller
follow hashtag voller voller follow
hashtag instagram followers hashtag get
more follow us at dann gibt es solche
profile die das dann auch machen wenn
man die daneben wie verlinkt und keine
ahnung also das sind so diese leute die
dann auch meistens im profil stehen
haben hey folgt mir ich folge
zurückliegt von mir ein bild ich gleich
zwei bilder zurück oder irgendwie was
gibt es da noch made the blue button
green oder so wenn man dann so abonniert
und was also war ich hasse solche leute
wenn die irgendwie so schreiben so
vollausbau voll beladen in mann soll den
leuten folgen die man folgen möchte
nicht so a das genauso wie stadt forst
bei youtube damals es ist einfach
wahnsinnig mega eklig dritten spiel den
eigentlich in den zweiten punkt auch
noch mal so ein bisschen mit ein und
zwar ist dass diese erwähnen mich mal
oder shout out heißt es glaube ich einer
fachsprache das ist halt immer so dass
es bei mir zum beispiel ich kratze mir
einfach so mit einem auge dollar
das ist halt bei mir vor allem sehr oft
beieinander so leute schreiben wie hey
conny erwähne ich mal in einem video
oder erwähnen mich mal im instagram post
aber das ist auch bei anderen leuten auf
instagram halt so dass die dann einfach
so unterschreiben hey gmbh oder art und
sodann - menschen macht es glaube ich
manchmal die post an in welche fotos von
irgendwelchen leuten und dann voller
höhe vor moore und annette und 1000 mal
das profil von der person verlinkt und
so so leute die einfach so erwähnen mich
mal macht man schaudert und so auch mag
ich nicht drauf ganz darauf an was bei
mir auch sehr oft ist und zwar dass die
leute bei instagram mit youtube themen
ankommen ich möchte das ganze halt so
ein bisschen beschränken in den youtube
kommentare könnt ihr euch über youtube
und unterhalten halt über das video was
dann da ich da hoch geladen habe zum
beispiel lädt das video bei youtube
unterschreibt dann droht also kannst das
doch machen tipps dies das anders bei
instagram ist es halt so dass man
eigentlich das foto kommentiert aber
wenn ich dann zb ein foto von mir postel
und dann so schreibe jetzt erstmal zum
sport fahren und ein foto von mir auf
dem fahrrad und dann kommen da
kommentare darunter hague andy ladner
hero hoch oder irgendwie sowas vor allem
hat man mehr hofmann hat die täglich
diese 20 minuten begrenzung und mehr
darf ich auch nicht hochladen
aber dann werden wir darunter dann so
tipps gegeben zum beispiel das aller
westlichen video hoch wo ich im auto
sitze halt ganz einfach so geht in die
10 sekunden oder so sondern ist darunter
ein kommentar vier doppel punkt 7.30
sowie man wenn man eine stelle im video
markiert so 4.37 du hast aber irgendwie
diamanten übersehen oder so so und einem
instagram video da dachte ich mir so
hell 47 weiß das video geht nur zehn
sekunden danach diana der bezieht das
auf youtube
genau kann ich auch wissen dann fünftens
gibt's diese hashtags süchtigen die
einfach alle möglichen heftig benutzen
ich weiß nicht ich glaube es gibt es
gibt so eine instagram statistik website
die es in die stadt ist
die grimms der start i gramm irgendwie
so heißt die glaube ich und da werden
ihnen wie immer so die aktuellsten
hashtags angezeigt so wo darunter ist
die meisten fotos gibt weil das verstehe
ich nämlich auch nicht altern ezb ein
kumpel von mir letztens ein foto hoch
wir trainieren ist also
wie die fußball spielen oder so drunter
hashtags love girlfriend bad es alle
möglichen hashtags 7 nichts mit diesem
foto zu tun haben auch so was wie weiß
nicht nature food borne install food so
was du alle möglichen sachen die nichts
mit dem foto zu tun haben damit dass
irgendwie in die kategorie reinkommt
dann damit dass dann immer mehr leute
sehen also einfach dieser hashtags
süchtigen und da spielt auch dass der
nächste punkt an und zwar einfach diese
heftig erfinder wo ich eigentlich auch
zu zähler halt einfach die halt
irgendwelche total kranken hashtags
einfach so erfinden
also es gibt ja diese hashtags die halt
so die zeit zu gibt sowohl unterhalb
millionen fotos sind ich glaube hashtag
love sind glaube ich wie viele fotos 20
millionen oder so ich weiß nicht ob der
lange mal reingeguckt aber dann geht es
an die leute die halt so hashtags
erfinden wie zum beispiel ich zum
beispiel platz und foto mit mir nicht
mit einer kerb hoch macht den gc steckt
ja ich glaub immer mit cap und ein
hashtag nein das war ironie oder ich
sowas so richtig würmer hashtags einfach
nur und ja das finde ich eigentlich sehr
geil wenn leute immer so herrscht excel
eigene hashtags erfinden weil sie mich
das mag ich an gibt die leute die einem
folgen und dann and folgen die direkt
wieder also ich merke das jetzt nicht so
habe ich weiß deshalb von freunden von
mir die mir das erzählt haben dass zum
beispiel so ein mädchen hat ein kumpel
von mir gefolgt und dann einfach wieder
entfernt und man sieht ja nur wenn
jemand allen folgt und ich wenn jemand
einen and folgt es ist weiß nicht da
sieht man halt nur damit will die wollen
ja zu zeigen so höre ich folge dir dann
drückt aber ganz schnell wieder entfalle
und ich hoffe der vollbild zurück wieder
so komisch geguckt ich werde jetzt
kommen wieder tausend facebook fotos für
kupfer was ich kann
richtig behinderte dann die leute die
die immer gleiche art von fotos machen
also immer die gleiche pose irgendwie
immer weil sie nicht immer schön viel
ausschnitt und dann vorm spiegel und
doug face oder sowie luca einfach immer
irgendwie so zog ich nahezu immer so
grund sind die stehen dann irgendwie so
so keine ahnung so gucke ich irgendwie
meistens oder ich habe auch schon drei
fotos hochgeladen wo ich in meinem bett
lag und so dass alles so gut morgen oder
guten 8 oder sie halten also die
gleichen die gleiche art von fotos ich
finde dass auf der einen seite irgendwie
total langweilig ich finde dass bei mir
selbst auch langweilig wenn ich das
sehen würde
aber auch für andere art und weise
irgendwie auch witzig wenn man sieht
dass die im
das gleiche macht die person die für die
irgendwie wollte nicht so 2 teilig ja
dann die leute die mich besonders am
meisten nahezu aufregen und zwar die die
einfach name kopieren status kopieren
oder auch teilweise fotos kopieren es
gibt leute
einer der hier der heißt irgendwie
konkret meinen namen geklaut das ist ein
fake der lädt so bilder hoch ja schickt
mit paysafecard 'nen und die kommt in
reihen- oder jahr schickt mir dies und
ich mache ich erwähne ich in dem video
und so oder es gibt so viele leute die
mittel ich hasse bei instagram laser
luca nicht konkret laser luca als ich
also laserdruckern und das ist halt
irgendwie mein name weißen ich den hut
kenne ich schon denn so hieß ich auch
damals mal irgend welchen spielen und so
jedenfalls gibt es auch so viele leute
die da sich dann irgendwie laser laser
finn nennen oder laser kathrin oder so
weisen jetzt ist es gibt aber es gibt
richtig viel so laser nahm neuerdings
und das witzigste starten dann auch
immer ich hab's anspruch bei mir im
profil der heißt hallo ich bin luca bin
fünf jahre alte möchte später tierärztin
werden das ist so ein spruch weil sie
nicht den find ich irgendwie ganz witzig
den habe ich jetzt auch schon weil es
nicht den hatte ich auch damals dann
immer zum beispiel whatsapp als status-
und so was alles aber den hat
mittlerweile auch so viele und so dumm
kopiert so hallo ich bin finden bin vier
jahre alt und möchte später tierärztin
werden so richtig chrome bestehen wie
weil sie nicht so leute die einfach
alles kopieren oder die leute die
einfach so fotos von autos nehmen die
irgendwie anders geschossen laden die
dann einfach bei sich hoch oder
irgendwie von so cocktails oder
irgendwie so etwas nicht die fotos von
denen sind das zuerst für so eine sache
ich laufe nur bilder hoch die ich auch
dann in dem moment mache weil was bringt
mir das das ist so in die scheiße wenn
ich ein foto vom eiffelturm hochladen
und zehn minuten später 1 von beat
werden so yu bin gerade mal ganz schnell
von da an von paris nach london geflogen
also das mag ich auch nicht so dann
zehnter sache leute die einfach es ist
einfach speziell auf ein bild bezogen
jeden montag finde ich in meiner
timeline zehn fotos montag nur noch fünf
tage hier nächstes wochenendes wieder
wochenende ja
mein gott ich habe selbst im kalender zu
hause ich weiß dass montag ist meine
lieben freund und nein ich mag montag
auch nicht also jetzt gerade mag ich
montag ich hab nur drei stunden und ich
muss nur gleich für eine stunde wieder
hin also vier schulstunden am montag das
ist relativ geil aber ja ich hab's
begriff meine damen und herren ich weiß
dass montag ist es regt mich ja auch
immer mega auf welches jeden montag 10
millionen fotos mit montag einfach ich
weiß gar nicht wie viele fotos gibt's
unter dem hashtag montag okay ich gucke
hat man nach es gibt 77.000 fotos mit
dem hashtag montag und auch wieder so
die sache mehr hier ist ein foto vor
vier tagen hochgeladen und es ist ein
foto von ihm so einer katze oder so was
hat diese katze mit montag zu tun alter
um ein gott wieder gezeigt so ein typ
sein wie zb steck montag brust bizeps
ach ja okay vielleicht weiß chase aber
das ist so weiß nicht das ist so unnötig
und er will be held monday monday schon
wieder die who noch eine woche da sie
die wochenende ist man der held the face
wenn montag ein gesicht hätte auf sich
fokussiert egal
naja behindert einfach nur so leute das
war mein video über instagram
stereotypen wenn ihr auch weitere
stereotypen kennt dann schreibt sie
einfach in die kommentare das wäre auf
jeden fall mega witzig ihr könnt auch
einfach mal eure freunde markieren nicht
ob es geht mit google+ oder irgendwie so
oder wenn ich das foto hier auf wenn ich
das auf instagram gewählt das
wahrscheinlich auf boston dieses video
und dann markiert einfach eure freunde
mal wenn die das irgendwie auch so sind
so stereotyp und sonst würde ich sagen
wollt ihr dass ich irgendwie nächsten
kontakt auch sowas machen wieso so
typische leute irgendwie allgemeine im
internet oder typische leute auf youtube
dann schreibt einfach in die kommentare
harry diese kameras sogar sie geht
einfach aus nein schreibt einfach was
ihr sonst so haben wollt in die
kommentare und dann würde ich sagen euch
einen wunderschönen tag
entschuldigung das selbe kontakt erst
heute kam der kontakt der nächste konter
computer prozentig am sonntag wenn nicht
dann
rutsche ich eine rutsche runter aber
angezogen letztes mal kann man ja passen
da musste ich keine rutsche runter
rutschen
dies habe ich nichts gesagt na ja 3